that's about your new film this looks
interesting belittle ours this is a
comedy set in the Middle Ages yes 13:49
and it's based on it's an adaptation of
the de Cameron which is a compilation of
short stories from the Middle Ages
that's fascinating yeah now religion is
a subject in in the film I think we have
first of all publicity photo from the
movie there you are as a I think they
had cigarettes back then but this is you
guys chilling the I'm told that the the
church the Catholic Church not so happy
with the film they I mean they haven't
even seen it yet so maybe they should
wait and see it before they get angry
but yeah there's I we brought it move
this is an actual movie poster we didn't
doctor this this is a movie poster it is
trash pure trash the Catholic League I
don't know why you guys put that on the
poster I don't see how that's but
whatever you guys thought you know let's
just be honest and tell people let's you
know we don't we don't have any secrets
here yeah it's a very Christian trait
your honesty so they're unhappy with the
film do you think once members of the
Catholic Church see the film they will
be happy with the film oh so you went
from basically just give it a look
before they judge to they don't need to
because it's going to make them really
angry I mean why I don't I mean I just
want everyone to like it I mean you know
if they like it they like it you know
get over it if they don't like it's it's
not about it's not an indictment on you
know Christianity or the church it's
it's a historical depiction of nuns from
the Middle Ages and that's you know it's
accurate what happens in the film so
they I don't know why they're laughing
I'm I'm with you completely on this
they're the ones giggling
no I don't know I blame them yeah what's
so funny about you you wore a habit
throughout the entire film and I
understand that it was quite heavy it
was not like a modern habit it really
was like a Middle Ages it was yeah there
was a lot of fabric you can you can tell
in the smoking picture but yeah it kind
of like weighs you down and and but
again I liked being inside of it you
know I trust you it held you in
suffocated you a little bit yeah and and
it was helpful I think for all of all of
the nun characters because you know all
you see is this much of your face you're
totally desexualized and you really do
start to like feel depressed after a
couple hours of wearing it because
you're just kind of like oh man I'm just
like you know just a like a I don't know
like a lump inside of it it was it was
really great it had a great time
beginning of your sentences never match
the a
you